i hope everyone's connected now welcome
to the press conference
uh following the vtc on covet
coordination and health welcome to the
president of the european council and to
the president of the european commission
i first want to point out that we've
just released today's statement
on covet coordination so please check
our website on behalf of the 27
member states and i first turn to the
president of the
council please thank you good evening
everyone today we focused
on five critical areas in our fight
against traffic 19. vaccinations
new variants travel restrictions vaccine
certificates
and international solidarity we also
discussed
the lessons learned from this crisis to
strengthen
our health systems and improve our
european coordination
our top priority now is speeding up
the production and delivery of vaccines
and vaccinations
across the european union and that's why
we support the commission's efforts
to work with industry to identify
bottlenecks guarantee supply chains
and scale up production and we want more
predictability
and transparency to ensure that
pharmaceutical companies comply
with their commitments the second topic
is
the new variance we face new
mutants new variants so we need to adapt
our strategy we must continue to
identify mutations
as early as possible and that's why
enhancing our sequencing capacity is key
to these efforts
and we need to continue to invest in
vaccine research
to update our vaccines the third
point travel restrictions when it comes
to travel
we need to respect the common approach
we treat
non-essential travel may still need to
be restricted
but measures should be proportionate
and we must ensure the flow of roots and
services in the single market by making
use
of the green lanes i trust the
commission to make sure
that these principles are respected we
also discussed vaccination certificates
and we agreed to continue our work on a
common approach
of course more work needs to be done on
digitalization and on cooperation
with the world health organization but
we felt tonight
more and more convergence among us abund
about this important topic
and the european council will revert to
this matter
solidarity this pandemic is
global and we won't be safe until
everyone is safe so we affirmed our
solidarity with third countries
through travax and the sharing of
vaccines
with our neighborhood and beyond for
instance
just yesterday six hundred thousand
doses
of coverage vaccines were sent to ghana
the first to be shipped and delivered
with
more than 2.2 billion euro already
donated by the european union
and member states we are a leading
contributor to covax
and to agree to continue working on a
way to share vaccines
and especially health workers should be
among the first protected our help
should go all those in need including
in africa western balkans eastern
partnerships
latin america we also started
discussions on the lessons learned
from this crisis and how to make our
health systems
stronger and more resilient for the
future
multilateral cooperation is key not only
to tackling traffic 19
but all future health threats
we are committed to improving global
health security
through a strengthened world health
organization
and i propose an international treaty on
pandemics
and we are getting more and more support
for this idea
not only in europe but also outside
of europe
[Music]
finally finally one words on russia
we will have a strategic debate in march
on
our relationship with russia and i would
like to repeat again
we condemn the treatment of alexi
navalny
and we demand his immediate release
on monday foreign minister switched a
political agreement to impose
restrictive measures
against those responsible for his
arrests and sentencing
and the decision will be formalized next
week in the framework
of the new european global human rights
sanctions regime
we also strongly condemn
the attack on a delegation travelling on
a world full program field visit
in the democratic republic of congo and
to express
our deepest sympathy to italy and our
condolences
to the families of the victims i thank
you
thank you mr president madam president
you have the flu
yes thank you so much we started let me
add a few
comments we started the leaders vtc with
a brief look at the epidemiological
situation
we observe stable and decreasing trends
in 20 countries
but increasing trends in about seven
others at the same time indeed there's a
growing covet fatigue among our citizens
it has been a very trying year
but we should not let up now not only
does the situation remain
serious in many parts of europe but we
must also watch out for the variants
that are spreading the b117
is by now in all member states but
one the south african variant is in 14
member
states and the brazilian variant in
seven
so there's a lot of challenge ahead of
us
the first task is of course to achieve
widespread vaccination we should
maintain
our utmost efforts um so the space of
the vaccination picks up
i shared numbers with the leaders by
sunday so the end of this week
more than 50 million doses of vaccines
will have been delivered to the european
union
more than 29 million doses have been
administered
as of today that's approximately 6.4
percent
of the whole population and if you
subtract children and teenager it's
eight percent
of the adult population to continue
increasing the speed
of our vaccination effort everyone has
to play a role so we are working with
the companies
to ramp up production and address
bottlenecks in the
supply we are ensuring speedy
availability of new production plants
in europe a good example is recently
biontech
starting the new plants in austria and
in germany marburg
this gave a little dip in that week but
they have caught up already with the
delivery of their vaccines
and the marble plant for example if full
functioning
by july will be able to produce 1
billion doses per year so that's a real
step forward
currently 41 industrial sites contribute
to the vaccine production
here in europe but many more could join
the effort
so we are strongly encouraging
cooperation between
industrial actors we are also addressing
the bottlenecks
in supply chains that goes from active
ingredients to specialized filters
and of course the fill and finish
capacity
we are on these issues also in
discussions with the united states
as they are an important actor on many
of these
just mentioned issues and let us also
stay focused
on vaccination in partner countries the
international dimension
the european union has announced the
doubling of its support to kovacs
to 1 billion euro if we take
the whole of team europe then team
europe
contributed 2.2 billion euros to covax
but in parallel as we know that
vaccine and kind is desperately needed
member states should make use of the
vaccine sharing mechanism we have
proposed last week
to organize potential donations of
vaccines
to our partners a brief look on the
variance
it's our task to detect and tackle
as soon as possible as fast as possible
variance that's the reason why we
launched last week the hera incubator
to build up our response to variance to
stay ahead of the curve
what we do need to do is support the
rapid detection of new variants
through cooperation with member states
notably
by increasing the sequencing
for that the european commission is
providing 200 million euros
to the legal framework that ecdc is
offering
to allow member states within this
legal framework to contract for
sequencing because we have to
detect on a regular basis
how the virus is spreading and whether
the variants
are spreading and how they are
developing
support of vaccine research is important
and development
so having established a kind of library
on the changes of the virus
we also need constantly to fuel
the research on adapting the vaccines to
the potential changes of the virus
we did start an eu white clinical trial
network
because if you develop
updated vaccines you need of course the
clinical trial to test them
and we need the amendment of the
regulation
procedures to accelerate the approval of
modified code cov19 vaccines
and finally to achieve all this we need
the engagement of the pharmaceutical
industry to boost the capacity
i am glad to say that leaders confirmed
their strong support
for the hera incubator today so we can
get
down to work now on the vaccine
certificates
um indeed we discussed this
uh topic as you know there are still
a number of open question political
question the first one
is of course what these certificates
will be used for but they're also
scientific questions that are still open
it's still
unclear whether you can transmit the
disease
even if you're vaccinated although
that is a concern that will wane as the
vaccination rate
increases we have promising data from
israel where the biotech
pfizer vaccines show that when you're
fully vaccinated with a double shot
you're no more transmitting the disease
so finally the decision on what you are
able to do
potentially with such a vaccination
certificate is to be decided
particularly
within each country but at the eu level
i believe we should use them to ensure
the functioning
of the single market and the good news
is we do not
start from scratch at the end of january
the member states with the support of
the commission agreed
what kind of data are needed
for such a vaccination certificate
for medical purposes so very simple it's
a uniform content
which kind of vaccines has been used
it's a unique identifier like an iban
code and a minimum data set that is
necessary for each certificate
now the member states need to implement
that in their health care systems and
their border systems
to make sure that their healthcare
system is fit for purpose
and we offer from the commission side to
coordinate on the standards like we've
done
with the tracing app and to create a
gateway
that connects the different national
solutions with each other
so that this information is
interoperable
over time this takes a while
so this takes at least around three
months
that is important so that expectations
are not too early too high
and it is very important that this
system is neutral to political choices
so you can pass the information this
person has been vaccinated
you can also pass the information this
person has a negative pcr test
or for example this person has overcome
covet
um and is immune so it's neutral towards
the information it's just the technical
work that has to be done now member
states will need to move
fast with the implementation if we want
such a
green certificate to be in place by
summer
beyond agreeing on the principles and
the technological
technology they will have to ensure a
quick and complete rollout in their
national health system
and in their border systems thank you so
much
thank you madam president um may i
kindly ask you to switch on your cameras
we've had a lot of requests so we won't
be able to take all your questions
but we're going to start with mark
peppercorn
first from the volksgrand mark can you
hear us
yes i can hear you thanks for the
question um there's one question
actually i have it's about an export ban
or vaccines i'm told that several heads
of state have actually
pointed to the fact that the uk and the
u.s have an export ban of vaccines
and at the same time about one-third of
the vaccines produced in europe
is exported so i would like to know did
the heads of state ask you to organize
actually such an export ban for
companies who do not deliver on their
contractual obligations thanks
[Music]
yes indeed the united states have an
executive order which is kind of
an export ban and a similar system is in
place in the uk
we chose a different approach the export
authorization mechanism because we
wanted transparency
so we want to see who
is exporting where and i was very clear
from the very
start on that is not directed against
any kind of
country but it is focused on the
question
does the company that is exporting
vaccines that are being produced in
europe honor their contract with the
european
union now if we look at
the pattern we see that the vast
majority
of experts is done exports is done by
uh biontech pfizer 95
approximately and the the rest
basically by moderna both of them
are honoring their contract so
that is fine with us we are in
discussions as you know with astrazeneca
where we there's room for improvement
what
um the fulfillment of the contract is
concerned so
here we have a very close eye on what's
going on
thank you turning now to
griselda griselda pastor merciless
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
yes this is a point where i could
take up another thought indeed as you
said
shall it is important to have a european
solution
because otherwise others will go into
this vacuum
as we know google and apple are already
offering solutions to the who
and these are sensitive informations
so we want to be very clear here that
we offer a european solution um
gisela the the time frame
the three months is regarding the
technical
development so uh we do need at least
three months for the technical
development
of an interoperable system
on the european level there's a lot of
work to do
for the commission on the european level
and the lots of work to do technically
for the member states
on the national level we are
we have agreed on the data set that's
important so this work is done
um it's a minimum data set the the
health
sensitive health data stay in the member
states
it's just the question is the person
vaccinated
or has the person a negative pcr test or
uh
antibodies because recovered from covet
as examples so very simple information
that is relevant cross-border for the
respective member states
and now indeed on a completely different
sheet of paper
is the question what are you allowed to
do with it
i think it is very important to keep
always a balanced
option open for everybody so you need as
long as you do not have access to the
vaccines
of course the option to have a pc artist
or rapid antigen tests
or other solutions that allow you to
access
the the options um that the certified
certificate
may give you but i think too that it was
a move forward today
on converging on this topic
thank you turning now to uh nicos nicos
crysolaris from bloomberg
nicos yes hi
i understand that you shared some
figures uh with
the leaders unexpected vaccine delivers
in in the second quarter and
specifically also on this on the third
quarter which i
i don't think in their public would you
mind sharing them
with us as well and also reassuring us
whether vaccine supplies in the third
quarter are sufficient
to achieve the target of the 17 of the
population
by the end of summer or even earlier if
supplies
should be
should i start yeah okay
so uh first of all um of course
um the the the slides can be shared
it is um uh a projection
of uh confirmed deliveries uh from
companies where we do have already the
schedule
um then deliveries pending confirmation
and uh planned deliveries of vaccines
that
at the moment being have not been
approved like johnson johnson or cuvac
for example
so this is no problem
and yes we are confident that we are
able to reach our goal
that at the end of the summer we will
have offered to 70 percent of the
population
uh the vaccination the adult population
these are 255 million people
in the european union and if we look at
the planned figures um this is a goal
that we're confident will reach
thank you um we're going to take a
question from mariapsara
as well maria
i hope you can hear me we can yes hello
mariet sarah from opentv
greece a question about the scale of
the scale up of the vaccine production
in the eu
did you discuss the release of the
copyright
of the vaccines the patents what is it
one of the options that you could
discuss or see
in the future
so um on the licensing
i am a supporter um
what the voluntary licensing
sharing of licensing is concerned
we see that companies start already
working together for example
of course you know that biontech is
working closely with
pfizer um kurovak now working with
bayer and astrazeneca and johnson
johnson
are working together with sanofi sanofi
is offering their
capacities to produce either astrazeneca
or johnson johnson
that is the right way to go i am
so clear on
limiting it to a voluntary exchange
of ip rights because
we will not only have to produce the
vaccines we have right now
but we need the whole exclusive
scientific knowledge
that is in these companies for example
with the new mrna
vaccines to be able to adapt these
vaccines with a trained personnel
rapidly
to potential mutants so uh the
cooperative
work with the public private sector
is in my views the the way to go
um this does not limit for example ideas
that you can also license
in that model
sites for example in africa
to be better equipped
to deliver on site but
my strong advice is to stay with a
voluntary mechanism
i have one more question um for both
presidents from
victor danice from czech radio victor
yes hello thank you very much i will use
just one of
the questions on madame president on
travel restrictions uh have you heard
any commitments from
the six member states not to be from
germany
or that they will ease the measures on
borders
that they will comply more with the
advice of european commission
with the trouble restrictions thank you
so uh we have this
been discussing uh these topics um
so i think it is uh very important to
keep in mind
that there are council recommendations
that unanimously
uh the member states held agreed upon i
think three weeks ago
on how to deal uh with cross-border
topics
and how to deal also with the occurrence
of variants
um i i see that there's always a
conflict between the health situation
and the free movement that has to be
um has to be solved on an
uh case-by-case basis but
um the restrictions have to be
proportionate that is very important
so for example if you look at the truck
drivers
there was a good reason why we
introduced and spring the green lanes
they are crucial to keep the single
market open and the flow of goods
within the single market so we strongly
recommend
to keep these green lanes open we see
that the truck drivers if you look at
the truck driver population and if you
look at the
testing scenario they have a very low
risk of infection lower than the general
population so there are reasons why
these green lanes are in place and they
do work
and i also strongly emphasize that we
need solutions for the cross-border
workers
we have regions that are dependent
that workers can cross the borders a
classical example is luxembourg
where the healthcare sector would just
not function anymore
if the cross-border workers from the
neighboring countries couldn't
commute every day to their their
workplace in the
hospitals in luxembourg burke so
what i see is that
after the initial difficulties now
it's more differentiated the restriction
of movement
i think the most important part is that
the different
regions the different member states
speak with each other
and stick to the recommendations and
then find a solution appropriate to the
epidemiological situation
thank you madam president and mr
president for this press conference may
i point out that tomorrow
at 8 30 we'll already have a doorstep of
the president of the european council
with the secretary general of nato and
our session starts at nine thank you and
see you tomorrow
[Music]
you